foreign
such a pleasure to have you here with us
welcome to Stanford
see so many folks
absolutely since we all know Adobe to be
a leader in digital experiences and
digital imaging we thought it was
appropriate to start with a few images
from your own digital footprint
as long as Photoshop was used in the
creation or editing of that I'm okay
so at first I found pictures that one
might expect ones of you meeting with
other Tech leaders like Satya Nadella
appearances on CNBC meeting with world
leaders like Prime Minister Modi and
Tony Blair
but then I looked further
okay
I also found you on stage with Fergie
from the Black Eyed Peas
hosting Billy eilish at Adobe
launching a collaboration with Lady Gaga
my question to you shantanu is as you
are building a career in Tech was there
any part of you that secretly wanted to
become a pop star
actually that's one that I can honestly
say the answer is no uh and true story
which uh this is uh Chatham House Rules
right and I know it's going to be on
YouTube but you will never repeat this
hopefully which
when uh Ann Lunas who is our CMO uh came
and told me that uh Billy eilish was
going to be at Max and we were going to
be having Billy eilish uh you know as
part of Max I said oh really I've never
heard him and so that that's how
ignorant I am of you know some of these
new age musicians but no I mean I I had
no desire no bathroom singing
um the only thing I wanted to be was a
professional golfer or an athlete so
that was very much part of it but that
didn't transpire either sankal
well in case you ever change your mind
we took the liberty of using your very
own Adobe Photoshop to visualize what
that might look like okay and here it is
thank you
if you could give me a little more hair
maybe that would be you know more in
line with the rock stars of the old
right well we can come back to the
career that you did choose and you had a
fascinating Journey I'd love to start at
the very beginning you grew up in
Hyderabad in Southern India your mother
taught American literature your dad ran
a business in industrial Plastics tell
us about the Narayan household and what
were you interested in
oh it was a very happy childhood as you
said you know my father actually went to
uh School in Urbana he studied
electrical engineering here and then he
went back to get married to my mother
and you know education was always
something that was considered critical
in the Narayan household I won elder
brother he's also in the Bay Area works
for a chip company here
and you know I went to this incredible
school that we were talking about a
little bit backstage where you could
pursue anything from academics to
extracurricular activities and so you
know I was the captain of the debate
team I participated in plays I edited
the school magazine you know anything
but academics was sort of what I what I
used to focus on and it was a great City
to grow up
and you know my mother was as you said a
professor of American literature so I
wanted to be a journalist actually
growing up and I've said that a lot but
in India you know the general wisdom or
conventional wisdom at that point was
that you either grow up to be an
engineer or you grew up to be a medical
doctor and those were considered the two
uh professions that most people followed
and I hated the sight of blood so I
guess engineering was the lesser of the
two evils so here I am you were
interested in journalism you mentioned
engineering at one point you were also
on India's national sailing team
uh as you you know as you were exploring
these multiple passions did that have
any impact on your future aspirations
well again uh you know the sailing was a
fun thing I mean we I grew up as you
said in a city called Hyderabad and
Hyderabad has this Lake
um hyderabad's actually now become one
of the larger software centers in India
I think Google Microsoft Facebook all
have big centers but it was this really
small town and um you know sailing was
again one way to you know not hit the
books I mean anything to not hit the
books was sort of the theme growing up
honestly and
but I think just doing these different
things uh you know in many ways it
teaches you what you like to do and I
think what's an equally important lesson
it teaches you what not what you don't
like doing and I always tell that you
know uh for people because I think
career choices or or choices of what you
do so uh you know I think and that's the
beautiful thing about undergrad
education in the US
in India when you do undergrad education
I think four years of engineering I had
one elective that I was allowed to take
I think in my fourth year second
semester or something like that but you
know just getting exposed to all these
things I think just teaches you to adapt
and maybe uh you know think about
different areas so it was fabulous yeah
you eventually did hit the books you did
your Masters here in the US and then
came to Silicon Valley you started off
at an early stage startup and then a
much larger company in apple
what lesson stuck with you across these
two very different experiences
well I think the entrepreneurial genes
have always been a big part of who I am
and so as you pointed out my first
company was a company called measurex
automation systems and uh this was in
the uh mid-80s and what they were trying
to do was uh you know do for the process
control industry uh and the discrete
control industry how software could be
used in that particular case and uh you
know it was a fabulous experience
um in terms of being at a startup you
get all this opportunity to do a lot of
things and then as you pointed out you
went to Apple which was you know
significantly different in Silicon
Graphics uh you know where there were
much larger companies and I think in the
much larger companies I learned a lot
about how you plan for the upside and
maybe react to the downside and in a
small company you just I think realize
this aspect of never taking no for an
answer and I think that's something that
hopefully is still the Hallmark of how I
like to manage which is in small
companies you have to overcome every
single adversity that exists and you
know that continues to be one of the
things that I'm very passionate about
how do you create in a company like
Adobe this notion that you know
anything's possible because we
artificially uh you know limit our own
aspirations and so you know it was
actually both of those were great
experiences uh financially measurex
automation systems was not as successful
but I think also what makes the valley
such an amazing place is nobody cares
where you went as long as you get good
experience and I think that was the
other learning which is you know early
in your career get a whole bunch of
diverse experiences you know and I think
that's what makes the valley such a
special place nobody cares whether you
were quote-unquote successful in that
company it's all a question of how do
you get more tools and after apple and
silicon Graphics you tapped into your
entrepreneurial genes you started your
own company picture in the photo sharing
space and and the company also you know
faced some challenges over the next
couple of years as you look back on that
experience
how do you think about responding to
setbacks
what was the best thing that happened to
me I mean a picture I was this company
in the early 90s you know the movement
from analog photography to digital
photography was just happening and so we
said to ourselves hey maybe people will
want to share images and and share
videos uh New Concept correct
but we were way ahead of our time so to
speak because the business model wasn't
there and we sold the technology to Fuji
you know Fuji and Kodak were the two
large companies that we partnered with
um
uh and but I I really don't look at it
as a setback you know I mean I look at
it as it was incredible experience we
raised a lot of money uh at one point my
co-founder who is the CEO I told him
listen I don't think there's a business
model and we should return the money and
he wanted to keep going and so at that
point Adobe was actually potentially
looking to buy pictra they decided
against it and I'm like great you know
Photoshop has this incredible brand let
me go work at a much larger company and
so it was actually for me an on-ramp
into you know a much larger company now
truth be told I went to Adobe thinking
okay I'll be there for 18 months and
then I'll go off and start my other
company again and 25 years later
nobody's given me a job so I'm still at
Adobe
fair enough and at Adobe you know you
led different divisions from product and
Engineering as you were getting more and
more responsibility was there a moment
when you knew you wanted to be CEO
the answer is no I you know I mean this
is a lot of people ask this question
about you know how structured were you
in terms of you know uh ambition and I
first as you point out I joined Adobe in
January 98. in August 98 the company hit
a wall and you know Japan at that point
we had some serious issues in Japan so
the revenue dropped precipitously and as
a result they had to lay off 25 percent
of the you know company this was in
August I think August of 98 and you know
John Warnock the co-founder and Chuck
yeski were running the company and on
the on one day they actually led the CFO
the head of products and the head of
marketing go because they felt like the
company was not as functionally uh you
know they weren't executing as much as
they did which is a massive move I mean
think about it right it's it's staking
and so they asked my predecessor Bruce
Chisholm to run a lot of the products he
wanted to to reorganize I just come in I
was I was a general manager at that
point and Bruce wanted to make it
completely functional which was the
right thing because we were trying to
break down all the fief terms and and
get people to do stuff
um and so he asked me whether I'd be one
of the engineering leaders because I had
an engineering background first I
thought I'd be you know I was the new
kid in the block so I'd probably get you
know let go off luckily that didn't
happen and when he asked me to run
engineering for this one group
InDesign was a product at that point
Quark was the market leader in desktop
publishing and he said this is a really
important initiative can you take that
on and
uh you know I said yes because I think
you know way too many times people think
about is that good for my career and for
me that was an important initiative that
the company wanted to do and I said you
know if I do that well things will
hopefully work out and so I learned that
very early on which is you know people
like to do what they think they're good
at perhaps not as much of where they
either the impact is required for the
company or what a priority is and I
learned that very very early on and so
you know I've said great I'll take
initiative and then you know that was
luckily a successful project and from
there we did it we did other projects
but uh and then six months later
actually Bruce told me do you wanna I I
still remember this this was just before
December of that year
and he had five engineering people and
he had five marketing folks reporting to
him and as I said he had reorganized it
and he was clearly more on the sales and
marketing side so in December he came to
me and he said I can manage five
engineering people and I I thought he
was in effect letting me down and
telling me that I'm going to consolidate
all engineering under one of the other
four leaders because the other four
leaders were there probably a combined
75 years
and I said okay and he said uh would you
like to run all engineering for Adobe
and I said let me think about it yes
and you know sort of so things work out
and you you just sort of take the
initiative but I always wanted I am
always fascinated by the business of
technology and so I said I'll do that
but over time I'd like to run more
product management and conceive of
products and create products and he said
sure and so you know I think taking the
initiative always helped me get more
responsibility and yes at some point it
became clear that you know hopefully I
was being considered or groomed for CEO
but there are also you know things that
come along the way we bought macro media
then it wasn't clear because perhaps you
know the macromedia CEO at that point
also wanted to do it but you sort of
I've always gone with the flow and you
know even when I did my MBA I'm sorry I
went to the other school uh but when I
did my MBA most people told me that hey
now that you've got an MBA you've got to
stop doing engineering and you've got to
become product management you know
because product management and product
marketing is the track to becoming a CEO
and I'm like screw this I like
engineering and I'm going to keep
engineering so I it's it's worked out
for me in terms of doing what I what I
want to do and what I have passion for
that's fascinating and as a result of
your initiative you were able to have
disproportionate impact much before you
were actually named CEO that also draws
a connection to something else you've
talked about frequently which is
influence leadership give us a sense of
what that means and why is it important
to you
well again you know the the first role
that I had at Adobe was What's called
the engineering technology group and you
know we had divisions and divisions ran
different parts of the business
and we had this fundamental belief at
Adobe that if you have a great
technology platform that underlies all
of your products you know if color works
the same and the user experience is the
same and printing is the same then we
can deliver more value to our customers
by saying if you learn how to use one
product you can learn all these other
products
but then to your point
it could be perceived as you had zero
direct responsibility for a product and
you know most people like p l right and
I always tell people at Adobe there's
one p l you know get over it and I run
that p l or the CFO runs the p l but you
know that was for me the fact that I
could influence as many products and I
could be a client of as many products
actually gave me this bird's eye view
for how every product in the company
worked and
and I think people obsess too much about
who's in my direct line of
responsibility and what do I manage and
I'm like if you liberate yourself and if
you feel like okay through influence I'm
impacting Photoshop and acrobat and all
these other products it's actually a
very liberating feeling and so I think
for me the influence leadership is if
you can convince somebody who doesn't
work for you uh that you know they're
part of your extended team and
conversely if you can get ratification
as a leader from what others do whether
or not they work for you
that's actually one of the most
empowering things you know people like
to talk about this is what I did and if
that team becomes larger and larger then
you know it's more happiness and so I
think that influence leadership and I
and I encourage that a lot among my team
right now I don't like people saying
this is my you know if when I interview
somebody for a new job and people
typically come in and I say what do you
think the role is about you know it's
always an open-ended question and some
people will say well I think I'm
responsible for this and I have 80
people and this is my P L and I tune
them up
and if they come in and say you know I
think my job is to create new products
or serve this customer segment or
innovate in this area I'm like okay tell
me more so I I think influence
leadership for me is it's worked out and
so I I think it's I think it's
liberating and I think it's empowering
speaking of working out in your first
year as CEO Adobe had record revenues
extremely strong customer growth and
customer retention and then you run into
the recession in OA give us a peek into
your mind at that moment how do you
navigate this roller coaster
well in retrospect it's great I mean in
retrospect it's great at that time it
was terrible because you know as you
said 2007 I take over luckily I had
grown from within the ranks and so I
think the business I had a really good
sense of the business I had a good sense
of the products uh but when you get
record revenues your first year you're
like oh my God this is so easy even I
can do it you know and and then when the
recession hit because uh at that point
Adobe was a discretionary purchase right
I mean if you bought a previous version
of the product uh you could choose
whether or not to buy a new version of
the product and so there were things
about our business model that were
fundamentally you know now in retrospect
it seems so archaic but opposed to you
know the ability to innovate and so but
again the glass half full of that was if
that recession hadn't happened we
wouldn't have said we need a fundamental
change in our business model we wouldn't
have been the first company to you know
really transition which from the desktop
to the cloud so at that time it was hard
but I'll tell you so many Silver Linings
from that and you know I think in my
role you have to be an optimist the
first Silver Lining is when
the going get stuff you really realize
in a company who are the people you can
really trust who are the people who are
there with you they're not there just
because things are and you know that
management team uh we were together for
10 years and so I I think you you learn
a lot of things more through adversity
frankly because when things are going
really well I mean everybody believes
it's because of their efforts and
perhaps when things are not going well
you think it's because of somebody
else's you know inadequacies and you
know in my role there's no
there's nobody else that you can look at
and say it was their issue and so you
know you look in the mirror and you say
okay we can either be paralyzed by
what's happening in the macroeconomic
environment or we can look at it and say
what are the fundamental changes that we
need to make I'll give you one you know
a lot of tech companies are now laying
off people
and I was so impacted by the fact that
at that point
um you know we had to let people go it
was a macroeconomic situation where
discretionary purchase the revenue
dropped 25 you know our Revenue dropped
25 then you know in a software company
most of your costs are your you know
fixed people costs and I resolve to
myself you know which is like if I'm not
prioritizing things or if I'm not making
the changes that are required so when
the pandemic first came we're like let's
prioritize the heck out of our stuff
and shame on us if we find ourselves
where we're over invested in areas so
again
a long-winded answer to say you know
you know you learn things and maybe this
is the Asian part of my culture and
growing up you take the Long View of
things I mean what's the worst thing
that can happen if things go badly in a
company you get fired
I love that optimism
that I will get fired or that everything
will be fine
exactly you spoke earlier about an
entrepreneurial Gene that's always been
with this within you regardless of the
size of company that you are working for
or or leading at Adobe with a you know
200 plus billion market cap how do you
drive innovation without running into
bureaucracy
hard I I I don't think we've completely
solved it I don't think we've completely
solved it but a couple of lessons come
to mind I mean one is you know when you
look at Sand Hill Road you know the
world's wealth so much has been created
by Sandhill Road and there's so much to
learn from Sandhill Road and I think the
first lesson is you talk to any uh great
investors and you can learn so much from
them they invest in people
so I I think the first thing you do is
when you're trying to innovate and
you're trying to create a new project
you sort of look at it and say do I
trust implicitly the person who's
heading up that project
because antibodies do come out from
every part of the company because all
the power in an organization tends to be
in the products or in the groups that
are making money today right and so I
mean the first thing you have to say is
first all software there's an s-curve
businesses have a natural you know life
cycle and if you don't invest you know
some people call it phase one phase two
Horizon one whatever you want to call it
but you have to have a portfolio of
products so that's I think something
that we fundamentally believe in for the
earlier stage products you need to
provide sponsorship so that's a big part
of what I do which is going back to that
people is it somebody that I trust
because even by assigning somebody that
you trust you're sending a message to
the organization that that's important
um different cultures
um you can say let a thousand flowers
bloom and let the best idea win or you
could say no I want a few top down I
believe in the few top down so I said
these are three or four areas that we're
invested in so let let's innovate in
those areas and so at least we have a
philosophy and we have a point of view
on what we want to do
you take the Sandhill Road approach a
little bit about saying let's give them
a little money you know most companies I
think one of the pitfalls could be we
have annual product annual planning
Cycles so you tend to you know incubate
these products only at annual cycles and
you know what sandal does is if there's
anybody who ever comes up with a good
idea they'll find money right I mean
that old adage of in a car in a large
company you have to get if there are 10
people who are decision makers you have
to get all of them to say yes and none
of them to say no whereas on Sandhill
you can get one person to say yes and
who cares if the other nine say no so
you know we're trying to replicate some
of those things and I want somebody on
my staff to be passionate about each of
the new incubation projects and if
somebody is passionate about it then
they'll drive it and if there isn't then
you know
I it's okay and the other I think
realization that you come up with after
a while is
it's okay if you know a company like
Adobe you don't have to create
everything within the company you can
buy products you can you know acquire
early on in my career I would say when
we acquired something that people looked
at and said hey why didn't Adobe created
it you felt bad
and now you're like it's okay you know I
mean you have the capital you have the
brand go acquired because great ideas
come from everywhere and so I think
those are a couple of ways in which we
incubate and then maybe when we buy a
company we leave it uh isolated for a
little while because you know way too
often I think companies do the let's
acquire something okay now we've got it
but you bought that company because you
didn't have it right and so I think how
you manage the company and that
leadership is you know those are a few
of the lessons I've learned but we're
always trying it's hard that's so
interesting to hear the the whole Suite
of approaches that you would you would
take to drive that innovation
so over the 15 years that you've been
CEO Adobe revenues have increased 7x
you've navigated recessions geopolitical
turmoil are you saying I'm old in the
tooth or something here uh very your
experience your very experienced
as you look back over your your tenure
how have you personally changed as a
leader
you know I've changed a lot I've changed
a lot
um I think when you grow from within the
company I I think the first and I've
I've talked about this a fair amount so
but when you grow up first you know I
was an engineer by background I sort of
knew everything and
um
since my previous role was the chief
operating officer in many ways my role
was you know keeping everything humming
and
when we moved to the cloud and the
subscription model you sort of realize
that the job of a CEO uh you know it's
both doing the flag planting as we call
it and the road building
and I was I think a better Road builder
in those days than maybe a flag planter
because I sort of had this engineering
mind I was trying to connect the dots
and you realize when you're talking to a
group like this and you want to make a
big change
they're half the people in the room who
probably tune you out
if you talk about just the road building
because they want to know what hill you
want them to go you know conquer and
conversely they're probably half the
room
Tunes you out when you all talk about
hey I want to go you know win a World
Series and they're like but what about
next game and you know what are we going
to do and how do I uh participate in
that and so I think that's been one of
the big changes that I've I've made
which is the people amaze you amaze you
with the Ingenuity and I think part of
our roles is creating unreasonable
expectations and I try and do that all
the time which is if you can create
unres what you consider unreasonable in
expectations people amaze you with the
Ingenuity so I would say that's one big
area where you know I've sort of changed
uh what I do
I think the second big area I I would
say and this is I it everybody tells you
this but your focus on people in the
time that you spend on your leaders uh
that's you know you spend more and more
and more of your time on leaders and
hopefully coaching that's a big change
from where you would do execution
reviews to where you spend time with
people and hopefully uh both get
inspired by them and Inspire them you
know so I I think that's a big change
that's happened
uh
I think the third thing is things where
I look at it and I say I don't like it
and if I don't like it how do I find
somebody else who's more passionate
about that area to do it you know I John
Warnock again I've learned so much from
the two founders of the company and John
said something to me the day I took over
as CEO John said to me if you don't like
your job transfer you're one person to
blame I said is that you John I'm just
kidding
and so when you take that on we I have
this incredible incredible opportunity
to do what I want right
and so I focus on the things that I like
and you know previously I would be like
okay I got to do a little ir and I've
got to do a little PR and I've got to do
product and I go to spend I'm like yeah
I'm going to focus on where I want to
have impact and I'm feeling far more
comfortable about that which is where do
I want to spend my time because it's my
most precious commodity
and last but not least
I'm way more comfortable
than I was 15 years and knowing that I'm
going to be wrong a lot of the time
hopefully I'm not doing the same thing
wrong over and over again but you know
it's very rare in these senior roles not
just CEO that people come to you I mean
I I can't remember the last time my team
came to me and said all 10 of us are
unbelievably aligned on this we all want
to do this what do you think
you know they typically come and it's
like well I five want to do this four
want to do this one's undecided make a
call shantanu right and so I think that
dealing with ambiguity and uncertainty
and being just completely comfortable
that yeah I'm gonna fail a whole bunch
of times and I'm going to get it wrong
but I can change it I think that's the
part that I'm very much more comfortable
with that and so I part of the journey
that's fascinating to hear you mentioned
planting the flag and setting the vision
you in your seat you have a very unique
Vantage Point into the future of
technology the Creator economy digital
experiences what gets you excited about
the future
oh there's so much I mean you know I I
think the most recent thing I would talk
about is and clearly it's the buzz is
what we've done if you haven't heard we
introduced this uh product called
Firefly uh recently it's our generative
Ai and you know I mean at the end of the
day if you think about adobe's purpose
and what we are focused on uh we believe
in this notion of creativity for all
everybody has a story to tell
and if we can help them tell that story
you know on any medium using any device
then we're serving you know a larger and
larger set of community
and right now I think thinking about
the role of how we can use artificial
intelligence to make our products more
accessible more productive more fun I
think we're just at the very very early
stages of it uh I think we took a very
unique approach because we said we're
only going to license our models based
on the data that we have we're only
going to train it based on the data that
we have licensed for and I think that's
one in which uh you know if we can get
billions of people to use our software
I'm really excited about that I love the
word impact and if we can have impact
through that that's one exciting thing
and you know there's the other part of
adobe's business which is all about any
digital experience that you have
engaging with any Enterprise hopefully
there's a piece of adobe software that's
used in the creation of that whether
it's the website the email campaign uh
you know the analytics associated with
it and
the reality is when everybody talks
about digital transformation
they're talking about you know engaging
with a customer digitally and getting
that personalized experience that they
expect and so from the Adobe perspective
those are the two things that I'm most
most fascinated about on the personal
side I'm on the board of Pfizer and I
think if I was starting my career right
now I think the Confluence of technology
and medicine and the ability to you know
really get these incredible new uh
therapies and to Market that's one that
I'm particularly fascinated with
I've got one final question before we
turn it over to the audience okay
shantanu you've LED large companies
you've LED startups you've served on
boards you've invested in sports teams
you've basically done it all as you look
out into this room of many soon-to-be
graduates what's one piece of advice
you'd like to leave us with
well
I was you know I was saying this earlier
which is the world's your oyster I mean
I it's just I mean I think of think of
where you are you're at Stanford
University in Silicon Valley
and if you have a great idea uh you know
it's just I the world's really your
oyster and trust your instinct I mean I
again I the thing when people ask me for
advice I say I'm not very good at giving
advice and be careful about asking for
advice because you're getting what
you're paying for it uh but the thing
that I would say is you know what we can
be a sounding boats and when people say
do you think I should do this or not
it's like be true to yourself I mean
I've always said people do their best
work when they resonate with the mission
of the company so we always talk about
changing the world through digital
experiences and when you resonate with
the values of the company I you know and
that's not value judgment on different
values different companies of different
values but if you can do that if you can
wake up every morning and you know feel
like wow I resonate with the vision and
the values speak to me as a human you'll
do your best work
otherwise it's a job and it becomes a
nine to five so I you know do something
that gets you excited about waking up in
the morning
with that advice and with you as a
sounding board we'll turn it over to the
audience please raise your hands mics
will be patched to you and you can ask
your question hi I'm Cher I'm a second
year MBA thank you for being here
um as CEO you have the unique
perspective of establishing Partnerships
with across the tech industry and one
such extreme that happened many years
ago was the controversial public
disagreement with apple over the use of
Adobe Flash
but on the other hand you have also LED
very successful open data collaboration
with companies such as Microsoft and sap
so my question here is what do you think
causes some Partnerships intact to
succeed and others to struggle and how
might us as Future Leaders here go about
in thinking building that right tool set
and establishing the right power of
Partnerships in what seems to be a very
highly competitive Tech environment
it's a good question a couple of
thoughts come to mind I mean the first
is first go back to this you know uh
assertion that I have where some will
work and some won't work so be
comfortable with it you know it's it's
worse not trying Partnerships than it is
trying Partnerships and Apple's a very
good partner so for the record while we
may have had in the past uh you know uh
sort of uh questions about Flash and
whether or not it should be supported I
mean the Mac OS and iOS are are where we
deliver you know most of our Flagship
products and so the first thing I would
say is you know you've got to try them
because the ecosystem and the ability to
step on the shoulders of you know or of
other Giants it's a good thing
the advice that I would give is think
about you know is the business model
fundamentally where they can make money
and you can make money over time and
you're serving customers because those
are the Partnerships that tend to you
know uh stand the test of time I mean
press releases are cheap right I mean
with any events everybody is trying to
do a press release about how the two
companies are going to get together and
transform the world but at the end of
the day if there's a good economic
incentive right where the joint
customers or customers or both of you
make money I'll give you example you
pointed out Microsoft you know we were
one of the first companies that sort of
partnered with them on Azure before
Azure became this incredible uh you know
uh giant that it has become and we were
like hey we need uh you know multiple
Cloud providers we were on AWS as well
Amazon so we needed Microsoft and they
said they would get their entire field
organization to you know course lrs so
we were validating it and so there was a
good economic argument we were helping
them you know with making sure that
Azure meta needs and so when there's a
good business objective it's the same
with Google or Apple for us on uh their
devices when Apple comes out with a
brand new Mac OS if we can take
advantage of those incredible features
that they have you know then we're
serving our customers well who are on
Mac and they make money and we make
money so I think really putting yourself
in the shoes way too many times you know
I the mistakes we made is when we think
wow this is so good for us but we don't
take the trouble to understand is it
equally good for the other partner and
if that's not the case then it's going
to you know die on the vine because the
other company is going to start off with
good intentions but it's not going to go
anywhere so I think I would say take
that time to understand the economic
incentives because all of us at the end
of the day uh
we have less time than we think and you
know we're going to do the things that
are going to yield the best results so
that's what I would do
Namaste is
I work in strategic Partnerships and I
had a question which you just answered
so see that's my AI at work
I'm kidding so my question was really
next on AI
Adobe has been a great company who led
the world in Enterprise
transforming to the cloud
so now we are on the next phase of
disruption generative Ai and it impacts
greatly on Adobe products so what's your
vision to transform disrupt the next
phase of art making and creating art for
the companies and for people
I first have this fundamental belief at
least in my professional uh
you know a lifetime
generative AI in the creative and in the
art space is going to augment human
Ingenuity and not replace it
um you know I Jensen uh is a good friend
I I had breakfast with him uh recently
and you know it's one of those great uh
you know Pleasures that I have
privileges that you can spend hours with
somebody that you respect and you know
talk about where you see things uh Tech
going and you know we were talking both
about these models whether it's
autonomous cars or generative AI that
you know at the end of the day the
companies that are going to win are
those who recognize that there's a
complete workflow associated with it and
understanding because this notion that
I'm going to come up with an idea and
just describe it completely and get the
final output that's going to be a
minuscule uh percentage of you know what
people do and so if we can think about
okay you're going to augment human
Ingenuity how do you make it and the
notion of co-pilot that everybody talks
about I believe that as well which is we
have the footprint with all of our
applications how can we help people with
that and so we've we've sort of
approached generative AI as again if you
have this vision of creativity for all
if you believe there are billions of
people the biggest thing that most
people fear is the fear of a blank page
you have this idea you want to create
something you know uh I was recent I
recently became a grandfather and so
when I became a grandfather I was like
okay I got to do this announcing my
grandson and I'm like oh my God I you
know and and people have higher
expectations of me if I'm working at
Adobe you know that piece of content has
to be great but so you use it as an
on-ramp to start doing it so we're
really looking at it first from
how can how can we design this to be
commercially safe I think that's a big
issue uh and then how can I also use
that as a business model which is if
we've designed it using Adobe software
if I go into a company like Disney how
can Disney Create a model that's only
specific to Disney where it's their
content and the Adobe license content
but only available to Disney so that's a
business opportunity for the consumer
it's a business opportunity because it
enables them to be more productive and
creative for the person who wants to
create art maybe they now are able to
generate more art and make that a
business right I mean Adobe is also in
the Adobe stock business so I think the
advantages are so much and then last the
big area that we're focused on is what
we're calling this content authenticity
which is uh it's an initiative we now
have 900 companies it's all about the
provenance of content and how do you
understand when somebody creates that
content how can you actually monetize it
effectively so you know I think with
with all Technologies one of the things
we talk about at adobe's purpose we have
three things we talk about Adobe for all
creativity for all and Technology to
transform and you realize that
technology has this incredible power
but there are potential users of that
technology that are potentially harmful
and that's a responsibility that a
company like Adobe has to just take and
say let's understand that we can't have
our head in the sand and say you know
it's not going to happen and ignore it
because then somebody else is going to
you know uh experiment with it so I'm a
big believer the generative AI will
actually bring more people into creative
it'll require more differentiation at
the end of the day uh but in a way how's
that different from we have this uh you
know online community called behance
think of it as LinkedIn for Creative
professionals tens of millions of people
they all produce stuff people get
inspired by that and so I think
generative AI also has the ability to be
inspired certainly there is going to be
disruption I'm not uh you know in denial
of that but if you come up with these
assertions that's again you know one of
the ways we we run the company is let's
have some core assertions
and you know even for a startup idea I
want the core assertions if somebody
says hey I need an hour to explain my
idea I'm not interested and so I think
if you have these core assertions clear
but I I'm a I'm very excited and I think
we're in the early stages uh of you know
what what that can be the generative AI
is new AI is not new for us I mean if
you've used our products we have
features like content aware fill and
things that you look at it and say oh my
God that's magic and so you know it's
just a different kind of magic that's my
belief I'm harshit I'm a second year MBA
student here
um looking back back at your life
what are the ways that you have found
creative inspiration and how how do how
do they nourish you today
inspiration from so many things so it's
hard for me to look at one you know
aspect at Adobe I'm a big believer in
you know we hire a lot from uh college
and it's like go spend time with them
right I mean the ability to I I think
one of the attributes I hope that people
will say about me is I'm intellectually
very curious
and if you are intellectually curious
then you're learning something in every
aspect of of what you do but I I think
for me a lot of it comes from people so
the inspiration from people is when you
sit with a product team and they're
talking to you about the stuff that
they've been working for this morning
before coming in here I was like okay
there's a product called Adobe Express I
want to sit with that team and you know
I want to really understand what that is
so inspiration comes from them
um I have my self-help group you know
when I took over a CEO that that's one
other piece of at least learning for me
uh which is find people with whom you
can share what's going on you know these
jobs become lonely it doesn't matter
what the job is and uh you know one of
your own Alum John Donahoe I would say
is one of my best friends and John took
over as CEO of eBay PayPal when I took
over a CEO of adobe Brad Smith took over
as CEO of Intuit at that time
um and so you know I have the self-help
group where I can go tell them anything
that's on my mind and you know there's
no BS and so that's inspiration right
because you hear about what they're
doing
but most of all it's my family you know
I mean at the end of the day you know
that's where you get you know incredible
inspiration and so but there's
I'm an optimist by nature and if you
look at every one of these even if
something doesn't go well you know I
always go back and look at it and say
did I learn something and if I can learn
something from it but you get
inspiration from so many and I thank God
I mean I again I know you didn't ask
this question I'm a big believer in work
at work okay Adobe has never taken
attendance we'll never take attendance
we trust people but I don't know how you
build culture I don't know how you grow
somebody's career if they're completely
remote or hybrid and so I you know thank
God that we're you know mostly behind
all of this and we are back at work and
I get inspiration from people
that that's what I get inspiration from
I think we might have one more question
yeah hi uh my name is tanmay and I'm a
student in The Graduate School of
Engineering I also had a question about
generative Ai and the Firefly Suite of
products so there's a lot of questions
about you know the copyright with these
algorithms and who owns it on the input
on the output of the Artists Own It you
know on the training data who owns that
and there's a few lawsuits also going on
with other companies yep so as a
business leader you know as these
products exist you know out there in the
world right now but there is also this
uncertainty on we haven't decided a lot
of issues about the ethics with these
products yet so as we as Adobe continues
to deploy these models how do you deal
with these issues
I it is one of the I if you actually
think about where I've spent my time in
this area it's also it's probably eighty
percent of time on the technology and
sitting with the engineers again that
inspiration learning all about you know
training models and inference models and
sampling and uh you know uh image to
text stuff it's been fascinating in the
technology I've also spent as much time
you know really trying to understand
derivative work and transformative work
and the legal implications we do have a
paper so uh if you're interested you can
read about AI ethics and what Adobe
thinks about AI ethics and biases and
all of that but and so you know I think
successful businesses you have to
navigate all all these aspects you have
to navigate the technology your
technology better be good if you're a
product company you have to have a
monetization model that's what I learned
at picture you didn't have a
monetization model at that point and you
have to engage with your community
uh but the lessons that I also learned
from the community in fact when we move
to the cloud I'll give you that example
when we move to the cloud Adobe was the
first company that said we're going to
move to the cloud boxers we're not going
to do it we got ranked as one of the
most uh green companies in the world
because we ship box we stop shipping
boxes you know I was we were the number
two company the greenest company in the
world and I'm like we don't even do any
manufacturing how come where the you
know greenest company PDF I know is
green because we you know help you not
you know kill trees but
you know you look at you look at all of
that legal stuff and that Community the
community didn't want us to move to the
cloud the community actually said that
this is a way that you know Adobe is
trying to do it they had a petition you
know there's this petition.org or
whatever that is and there was a
petition I always say there was a
petition to eliminate Senior Management
and then I clarify it was a petition to
fire as the CEO so all right luckily I
survived but engaging with the community
on that and recognizing that even when
they are people who are opposed to it go
really deeply understand what their
issues are
and are there issues fear are there
issues well intentioned if they're well
intentioned then you've got to go
address it if their issues are feared
there's not much you can do about some
of that stuff so specifically on Firefly
first uh you know our model is
completely trained we didn't train it on
behance data even though behance is an
adobe site we did not do that and so you
know we've identified what our model is
you've got to be transparent with your
customers on that you've got to
understand you know where the law is
going to head and you're right there's
some uncertain part of it but you have
to have your North Star as a company and
be clear about which lines you're not
going to cross
and if you can do that and if you can
communicate that to your customers
things work out if you're on if you're
ambiguous about that you know then I
think bad things happen in companies and
so our our job is to assert where we are
going
and then help navigate it and it's an
uncertain time but you know frankly in
the uncertain times uh good companies
should get stronger and you know that's
where opportunity is right for us and I
think we're coming at it from the
absolutely right intentions so I'm
confident about what we're going to do
thank you shantanu my name is srinivas
I'm from Stanford lead program
my question too is I'm just borrowing a
concept I read long ago from a book
called the Zen and Art of Motorcycle
Maintenance Robert persig we all grew up
reading that in India
so there's this classical versus
romantic
classical being the engineering the
number crunching the Romantic being
somebody who appreciates creativity art
and so on and so forth
you with Adobe or in a unique situation
where you encounter these two on a
day-to-day basis so how does how do you
exert your creative juices to come I
mean how do you appreciate the
creativity or the art part of adobe
you know I'm a big believer everybody
talks about stem I'm All About Steam I
mean think about it the world without
Arts would be a incredibly boring place
and so you know I I
it's how I run the company I you have to
get inspired right and whenever we have
business reviews uh since this last
whenever we have business reviews I
always say give me the narrative and
give me the data so actually I have the
best job in the world where you know if
somebody comes in and all they are doing
is giving me data after data after data
the you know what you talked about in
terms of the data then you lose that
Essence so the Zen of you know in fact I
use that expression all the time in the
company what's the Zen or what you're
trying to do you know inspired by that
book
but if people don't have that Narrative
of why this is going to be different
better
Etc then something's missing and so I I
actually am maybe uh you know trying to
blend the two and so the way I like to
manage is tell me the Zen of what we are
trying to do and I think that's at the
end of the day how you know you make
things different but make sure you have
the right metrics or data because that's
what we're all expected to do to
understand if you're making progress
because otherwise it's far too easy and
so I think that book inspired me to
actually try and find a happy balance
between both of them
before we close shantanu it's a view
from the top tradition to end with a
rapid fire round so I'll ask a series of
quick questions and you can respond with
the first couple of things that come to
mind okay first one two words your wife
would use to describe you
[Laughter]
family man
two words your kids May used to describe
you
these are tough I hadn't heard this okay
uh
competitive golfer
two words you would use to describe
yourself
blessed individual
and last but not least two words that
Billy eilish may use to describe you
who is this guy
continue it's been an honor thank you so
much for sharing your time
thanks a lot thank you
[Music]
foreign